en servant antoine président d'un groupe
de supporters du losc vous êtes comme un
fou vous avez fait la fête toute la nuit
on n'a pas beaucoup dormi ça c'est clair
incroyable c'est monstrueux c'est
monstrueux alors est ce que vous
comprenez que les images de la fed fasse
polémique pas clairement oui mais je
sais pas si vous êtes au courant allez
on est tous vaccinés ça y est as any way
to le nord et vaccine non c'est pas vrai
c'est le cas présent ça promet
grâce à martin a well écoute ça m'avait
envoyé des petits gâteaux secs un jour
j'ai animé nos missions a dit l'envoyé
les gâteaux etc c'était un piège
ah ouais c'est vrai mais sympa oui oui
moi ça me choque pas du tout bonnement
faut laisser les gens vivre le décerne
exploit pour les lillois de remporter le
championnat ils ont droit de faire la
fête et on comment on peut critiquer ce
alors que chaque semaine en france ya
des manifestations avec des milliers de
personnes en quoi ça ne me choque
absolument d'as au livre et j'ai trouvé
ça honteux et je vous laisse lire jean
kiffer viareggio une jauge à 1500
personnes vous étiez 8000 sur la grand
place
oui mais les autorités ont été débordées
monsieur peut-être que vous êtes vacciné
mais tout le monde ne l'était pas y
avait pas de masque si les cautions
franchement j'ai trouvé que ça gâche est
le titre lillois je ne comprends pas que
vous avez fait ça voilà je voulais vous
le dire que vous dites antoine les
autorités dépassées
il ya eu sa tête à sept interpellations
uniquement donc sincèrement était ultra
sérieux où on a fait la fête
ça fait un an qu'on subit la pandémie on
voit une saison magnifique
on est frustré de pas être au stade bien
sûr alors ça c'est effectivement il faut
être prudent
d'accord je l'accord gilles mais
sincèrement aujourd'hui hier soir
c'était une explosion de joie et je
pense pas que rld 1,6 en particulier
d'alors et moi et je pense ariab la
maison qui sort était dans une autre
ville ça aurait été pareil fournisseurs
alors bien sûr bien sûr il ya gagné il
ya des restrictions sanitaires etc
mais à un moment je vous dis moi ce
qu'ils ont accompli des dix doigts ses
râles des normes lille là je peux vous
dire ça fait des semaines et des
semaines qui sont pas sortis tous les
lillois et là c'était une raison de
faire la fête incroyable après c'est
vrai que c'est nous dit que tout le
monde est vacciné aline étudiants faudra
il faudra dire bravo à m martine aubry
oui surtout que le fait que tout le
monde soit vaccinale il s'est pas du
tout un bon argument mais vraiment pas
parce que en ce moment ce matin même
encore on nous a encore précisé et
certifier cette fois-ci par tous les
médecins que tu avais beau être vaccinés
tu fais quand même
très affecté et transmettre déjà
l'argument du vaccin après vous autour
de ce bateau des blogs fans de foot une
bouteille c'est une bonne blague
nous on a pas ce que c'est excusez moi
mais quand même ça aurait pu être un
argument après nous vous êtes tous fans
de foot autour de ce plateau
moi j'en ai rien à faire du foot donc
quand je vois ça et qu'après il ya des
festivals de musique qui sont pas
autorisés bah ça me fait chier mais si
mais si
mais alors